so who's in the bad place that would
shock me oh well Mozart Picasso Elvis
basically every artist ever every US
president except Lincoln that sounds
about right
what about Florence Nightingale that was
close but no she didn't make it how all
those amazing people down there it just
seems so hard to believe again it's an
incredibly selective system most people
don't make it here but you a lawyer who
got innocent people off death row your
special element by the way welcome to
New Hope oh it's perfect isn't it you
see in the good place every person gets
to live in a home that perfectly matches
his or her true essence cool so I guess
that's why my house for example is this
adorable little cottage whereas other
people might have homes that are bigger
like that one exactly oh I'm so happy
you get it yep maybe it's a test maybe
if you go to Michael then you tell them
the truth you'll pass the test and
you'll get to stay no way
I can't risk going to the bad place
maybe he's not actually like all that
bad
let's just get some information first
I'll ask Janet hey Janet how can I help
you what the fork who are you I'm Janet
I'm the informational assistant here in
the good place she's like this walking
database you can ask her about the
creation of the universe or history
there was a guy who lived in Avondale
Arizona around 2002 his name was Kevin
Pelton 'ok is he gay no really huh I
guess he just didn't want to have sex
with me that's correct
well that's fine I wasn't that into him
anyway yes you were okay Janet I have a
question okay what is the bad place like
oh sorry that is the one topic I'm not
allowed to tell you about I can only
play you a brief audio clip of what is
happening there right now okay
well it doesn't sound awesome
you